what can we do to be very humans here at
lad Bible we've come to a decision how
you sort the problem of morons oh my God
we're doomed yeah that's that's what's
killing us beaut you talked about this
we're going to start our own country
seems a bit ridiculous well it's about
to get more so there's been a huge
mucking issue growing over the last
twenty years that's completely
outrageous that's like one part of it
we're at way past critical level that
anyone said we should ever get even
close to that everyone is conveniently
turned a blind eye to plastic plastic 8
million tons of plastic get dumped into
our oceans every year
how important are the world's oceans to
you as a species our have become
addicted to plastic we are we can't get
away from it and it will not get away
from us
by 2050 that the weight of plastic in
the ocean is going to outweigh the fish
but also so many people get their food
from the ocean
and all that plastic is ending up inside
of us as well it's pretty sad we see all
that in the oceans there is so much of
it but in the North Pacific
there is now an area of trash the size
of France that arrests up now some
people say that it's not true this is
very much true maybe one day they won't
look so pretty
unless we do something now yeah I mean
what do you do how do you sort that
problem with no one doing anything about
this country size problem we thought we
would so welcome to the trash I
[Music]
what are they gonna do about this
treasure we need to do something about
it there has been a push to to to make
the United Nations understand that if it
had the rights as a country it might
cause something to be done about it
because we have to take responsibility
that unfortunately hasn't happened but
the awareness is there now you know
without the ocean we don't exist so
doubts on we pulled our heads in and did
something about it we need to take a
little bit better responsibility for our
actions and for our inventions like
plastic they think it starts with us
I mean if everyone worked on that
personally just positive gentlemen let's
try to not throw as much plastic in the
ocean that's a good start by becoming a
country others are obliged to clean us
up become a citizen of the trash aisles
today basically say I'm the trash I know
I will go through this trash oil
citizenship is a great pastry system
very low top three
[Music]
free bed Wow
so I'm very interested in it and thank
you for doing this and thank you for
including me in this and I will cherish
this
yo I'm nipa Bissell and I'm at Russell's
prints
hi I'm Moe fire it's amazing to be part
pressure and I'm Duty games as I will be
the best secretary for defense that I
can congratulations on what you're doing
and thank you for doing it consider me a
partner and helping show the world first
country made of trash is it lost this
earth is amazing in it's a it's a hell
of a time to be on it so let's try to
take care of thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]